[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of my favorite basketball analysts
john berry espn radio nba analyst former
nba player
he's been on the call throughout the nba
finals for espn radio
and he'll be on the call tonight nine
eastern game
six tipping off in milwaukee john thanks
for joining us
give me the player who has the most
pressure on them tonight
oh well everybody i mean it's
a knockout game so well everybody on the
suns
obviously uh i mean i know everybody
talks about
chris paul and it's this legacy i i
don't get caught up in that
i mean does it really change what kind
of player chris paul
is going to be looked at if he wins or
loses this nba final
in 10 years i think so why the hall of
famer
regardless what's the difference well i
think he moves up though john if he wins
i've heard this well
nash never won and stockton never won
you know then he leap frogs them
and then um i this is what analysts
tell me um do i think that uh chris paul
is better than john stockton i don't
uh do i think he's better than steve
nash i don't
um does he belong to be in the top ten
sure but is he a top five because he
wins he's not better than jason kidd
in my opinion so winning a championship
makes you better
than that i well i think that's how
people validate
greatness you know john elway needed to
win super bowls
to now be considered one of the great
quarterbacks tom brady's the greatest
because he has all these super bowls is
he more talented than aaron rodgers or
john elway no but i i if tim duncan
didn't have any championships
he'd not be a top 15 player top 20
player
maybe not but but i i just
i he's going to be the same player to me
whether this happens or not and i'm not
putting this series on squarely on his
shoulders he played great in the first
two games
not so great the last three uh
so it's not on him yes he's had some
blunders
uh in his past in in big playoff games
uh but this certainly isn't a series
where it's on chris paul to win or lose
i think there's a lot of pressure on all
the phoenix suns
but i think if you're the bucks you you
got to win tonight
you did win in phoenix but this feels
like a coronation tonight
they're going to be 60 000 people
outside that building tonight john
i understand and plus the four of us
on the radio that have to walk through
that if they win
so i i do typically cheer for the road
team
uh to closed out series it makes it a
nice easy walk home
uh no i think you're right uh you don't
want to go back game seven
in phoenix no way and look phoenix could
easily
be up in this series i thought game four
they completely gave away with their
turnovers they should have won that game
they outplayed milwaukee uh and so they
could have gone home and had a close-out
game in game five
that's not the case obviously they
got off to a great start in game five
and the game completely flipped
milwaukee
had uh they monty williams told me
yesterday the eighth best shooting game
in 1345 playoff games
the eighth best in the history oh i mean
that's
eighth best yeah i mean they they were
so they started that game 9-21 they went
32 for 45 in the second and third
quarter for 79 points
it was amazing and then phoenix almost
comes back and wins but
i i don't think phoenix is a fractured
team that
i think they're still a confident group
uh and
if they were to pull this off tonight i
would say that they would
win the nba championship they would win
game seven at home
talking to john barry he'll be on the
call game six tonight espn radio
tip off at uh nine eastern i was talking
to reggie miller yesterday and we were
talking about
shaq when the pacers played the lakers
in the nba finals in 2000.
he he shot 18 of 39
from the free throw line in the whole
series no
one game shaq was 18
of 39 in game two and they won
like imagine if the greek freak did that
john like
where we go man he went one for ten and
uh two air balls
shaq went 18 of 39. wow
and la still won the game yeah yeah
well so are you getting at maybe you try
that with giannis tonight
yes put him on the line yes yeah well
now he is at home where he's probably
more comfortable i
i don't know the stats per se on his
home road splits on what he shoots free
throw wise
uh he had gotten better and obviously
not so
good in the last game i believe four for
ten but it was a great miss
because they got the offensive rebound
and chris middleton
made the free throw to put it out of out
of reach but
uh yeah i mean i don't know is monty
williams saving this to to possibly do
it because they haven't done it yet
i know maybe maybe it's a poi if uh if
it gets down to a tight ball game here
you know but it's got to be after two
minutes obviously uh
so i i don't know i i doubt that we see
monty williams do that
and when it comes to free-throw shooting
and i've talked to former players and i
said look if you could shoot it
underhand
like your father famously did and you
could make lit let's say
77 of your free throws
and you're maybe a 50 free throw like if
you said to giannis
try this and you and you go 80 percent
would players be more likely to do what
your dad did
and your dad was one of the greatest of
all time like is it easy to teach that
style of free-throw shooting
uh i i think he could teach guys with
with the big hands i think it's an
advantage to do
you know i i've never really messed
around with it but i think if you have
really big hands and it's kind of a risk
[ __ ] thing where it's
it's not hard to do uh but i don't know
that guys would do it i
i mean i played with shaq you know in
what 97 whatever it was and
i used to joke with him about it he's
like i'm not looking like a [ __ ] like
that you know like
i'm not doing that's embarrassing like
what's more embarrassing
18
or doing that like i don't know if you
care enough
i certainly would hope my my if i coach
the guy i hope he'd want to shoot 80
as opposed to 50 regardless if he had to
put a pink tutu on at the free throw
line if it went in
do it did shaq practice free throws
i i shot with him every day every day we
went into free throw a breakdown of free
throws i was with him
17 out of 20 18 out of 20 every time
every time and then what happens
uh i don't know some people don't like
to be at that line i think maybe fatigue
it plays a factor if you're in the game
um
who knows i mean you're the center of
attention i know guys love to be the
center of attention in certain areas but
maybe not
standing on a free-throw line when
everybody's just staring at you
what's the best conversation you ever
had during a free throw
with the shooter or with another guy
another guy
well like the guy with like like first
base when these guys get hits and
go over there oh gosh i i don't know
i mean it would usually pertain to
something that was going on in the game
i mean it was another like
you know did people say stuff to you at
the when you were at the line
no it wasn't like
well you were pretty good free throw
shooter no i
i i didn't it didn't yeah i know i mean
yeah guys who might say something like
hey we need this one give us this one
yeah we know he'll give us this one yeah
whatever it's like yeah sure
free points man i'm not giving you in if
is there any chance chris middleton gets
factored into the mvp
if the bucks win yeah you know what it's
funny i was i was wondering about that
yesterday like
if middleton goes big tonight and
giannis is
you know okay what what did they do i
mean i know janice's numbers are better
uh but you know quite honestly chris
middleton's the go-to guy
of the milwaukee bucks now i know drew
holiday came up big
in the last ball game but when they need
baskets middleton i mean middleton made
some shots
in that last game the step back three
right in front of their bench
yeah uh he he and i i did the eastern
finals as well he had a 23 point quarter
a 20-point quarter
i mean when this guy gets rolling he
he's awfully difficult to stop though
uh you know typically they always go
with the big name guy right
yeah so you think you would think
giannis gets it
uh but middleton's been huge and then
drew holiday to bounce back after a four
for 20 game four
and play the way he did man
and he defensively he is a monster i
mean he he's
given chris paul fitz but you have the
booker situation and i don't know if
it's too much of a good thing john
where he's going to get 35 or 40
but is that good for his team as strange
as that may sound
well two straight games over 40 and he's
lost to both yeah
uh certainly not his doing but what
milwaukee's doing and
mike bunoser takes a lot of heat for not
being a guy that adjusts
and does different things during the
game i i think he's done a great job
is their their switching now is causing
phoenix to play one-on-one basketball
and it's either chris paul
or devin booker playing one-on-one their
assist numbers way down
their passes per possession way down
and the shot making has been incredible
what devin book the shots
he's making to get his numbers they're
con
i mean i don't remember many uncontested
shots he gets
he is working extremely hard and making
unbelievable shots so if you're phoenix
somehow they still shoot 55 percent in
the last game they still go 13 for 19
from three
but you can't expect to play one-on-one
basketball and make the kind of shot
you're making
on a consistent basis so tonight uh
you you've got to get some ball moving
and phoenix has not moved the ball
and credit milwaukee for making them a
one-on-one team
and credit devin booker for doing what
he's doing
but if they continue to play one-on-one
and don't get mikael bridges and ayton
and other guys crowd or involved i don't
think they can win
he's john barry espn radio nba analyst
you were on the lakers in
1998. he's something like that i don't
know i
i mean i was about eight different i
can't remember years it's just a little
difficult well no you guys got swept by
utah that year yeah we did
we did in the western finals and kobe
was what 19
19 years of age yeah his second year in
the league
and he took the last shot didn't he no
that was good before
that was his rookie year that was his
rookie year but he didn't he
he didn't play much i mean eddie jones
was the two guard
and and kobe played less than 20 minutes
a game in that second year
but did you see sort of what could be
with co or when did you
see that 100 every day in practice when
it was game
seven no like
we get ready to scrimmage right we're on
the second team and
he he wanted to uh he was going after
eddie jones every day
to show coach dale harris like no
this is my job i don't know why this guy
started and like literally
every day was game seven uh when we
started scrimmaging
i mean the guy was is driven as any guy
i've ever known
like michael jordan he's the he's as
close and john smoltz
are the three most competitive guys that
i've ever met
john smolt john smoltz as competitive
as anybody i've ever met 100
well you you played against kobe and you
played against
jordan you've just played golf with john
smoltz right
right i'm just saying okay no
he he's i'm i just he'll do some
gambling and
we'll gamble on anything and he's just
gonna kept some people oh yeah i'm
putting him there
except for tyler last week when he
choked down
down the stretch there oh sorry johnny
[Laughter]
that's pretty good though with you know
kobe but i'm sure that
i don't well what was eddie jones like
when does he know his days are numbered
when he's seeing this
that kobe's going after him i i don't
know
no because eddie was still still pretty
young and
i think he went to miami after that had
some all-star seasons so no
he no he he accepted the challenge um
but yeah everybody everybody kind of
knew like this kid right here
oh my gosh when he arrives it's gonna be
hello world like tiger right did shaq
know it
jack knew it of course because i just
wonder about that ego
you know those egos and i and i know it
wasn't there yet because
kobe hadn't had success but could you
feel like
you know there's only one king on the
throne here
you know no because i didn't think that
kobe would care
he just wanted to play and that's all he
wanted and that's all he did
like literally he wouldn't talk on our
planes he would i
believe he wrote a lot of lyrics of rap
music
and he would not we he wouldn't he
wouldn't join in our reindeer games of
cards and all that stuff like he
he would sit by himself write whatever
he was doing he would watch michael
jordan interviews
he would never go out in the city we
went to uh you would never see him
he'd be at practice and we'd play pra
one-on-one after
practice and if i didn't say i'm leaving
he would never leave the gym
no he wouldn't like i had to say like
i'm out of here man jesus
it's like we're two hours after practice
man
he would never leave no really so he's
watching michael jordan interviews
100 he wanted to be him more than
anything in the world
and be better he got close
yeah he's just closed yeah that that's
when we
and he wasn't afraid to say that he
wants to be michael jordan
whereas lebron is not michael jordan but
kobe
said look i i want it i'm going after
you
you wear 23 i'm wearing 24. like i i i
i'm one up when you i i but i loved that
that he embraced it he didn't he didn't
back
because a lot of guys have shied away
from it where it's tracy mcgrady
grant hill hey they're the next michael
jordan kobe's like
hey i'm the next michael jordan and
people are like come on you're 19 yeah
you know easy here then all of a sudden
we realized
he he had somebody that he had footsteps
to follow
he wasn't afraid of that yeah he he
loved the comparison
i mean that that's all he wanted i mean
i remember the first time
that well we played chicago when we
played him twice obviously being in the
west
and that game at chicago i mean this kid
was
bouncing off the wall before he got out
there
and you know the problem was we got our
we had our butts handed to us so
he didn't get to match up against
michael very much but
man the guy played like it was game
seven when we were in there down
25 i mean he he was something
did shaq run onto the court naked at any
point during a practice while you're
with the lakers
he did not no i never saw that
thankfully no
okay because i some of his teammates say
that
he was famous for doing that like he'd
go out there in just his socks and then
he would hug people
[Laughter]
i mean that guy's great too it's it's
amazing those two guys you know
that that happened because shaq is as
good a guy as you ever meet
he's he's just the biggest kid in the
world
complete opposites though right totally
total yeah yeah uh have fun tonight
and uh so you're rooting for the suns
just so you can get out of the building
safely
that's basically it yes
okay but one of the eight or nine teams
you played for was milwaukee
yes 30 almost 30 years ago well they
still remember you
a few people have yeah i do welcome back
to milwaukee's
it's great you should wear your jersey
tonight
i you know i have though it's the the
ugliest green remember the all shades of
green
on the side yeah that's what we were
yeah awful
the worst i have a terry cummings
autographed jersey
from that year from the the when you
guys had those jerseys so
yeah terry council yeah uh have fun
tonight
always great to talk to you safe travels
there john thanks
that's uh john berry of the mother ship
tonight at uh 9
eastern those are great stories about
kobe